hit it if you must but the viral cottage
cheese ice cream that everybody's making
is everything that's good to make a
raspberry cheesecake version you only
need six ingredients one of them
obviously being cottage cheese add that
raspberries brown sugar white sugar and
a splash of vanilla and blend it until
it's super smooth mash up some more
raspberries and graham crackers and add
everything back to the original cottage
cheese container layer by layer I like
to give everything a little just for
good to measure and then toss it into
the freezer stirring every hour until it
reaches the consistency of soft serve
I'm not saying it's better than ice
cream but it's Tangy light and creamy
and tastes just like cheesecake